their steak or their seafood and you
know a glass of wine
i think right now it's it's been a
takeaway so to have it back would just
be wonderful
for now the current restrictions on bars
and taverns that do not serve food
those will stay in place governor
sysolak also doubled down on the
importance of wearing a mask
keeping your distance from others and
not having large gatherings
especially with this holiday weekend and
normally labor day weekend it's a huge
weekend here in las vegas
the lbcv a says it brought in about 400
million dollars just last
year but this year it's a lot different
and officials are urging caution
hector mejia live now with the efforts
to avoid a spike in cases hi hector
hillary alex good morning and this will
not be a regular labor day weekend here
on the las vegas strip or anywhere else
and experts right now are saying
now is not the time to let your guard
down and here's why
as the weekend approaches experts are
warning about a possible
repeat of fourth of july weekend they
say it was right around that weekend
when states across the usa surge in new
coronavirus cases
the warning they're warning everyone to
remain vigilant during this pandemic
that means wear a mask social distance
avoid large crowds and if you can
keep gatherings outside we don't want to
see a repeat
of the surges that we have seen
following other holiday weekends we
don't want to see a surge under any
circumstances
but particularly as we go on the other
side of labor day and
enter into the fall we want to go into
that with a running start
in the right direction
here in nevada according to governor
steve sisolak case numbers for the
coronavirus are decreasing and so is our
seven day average on positivity rate
however
he said nevada is one of only 11 states
in the entire country
that still has a positivity rate above
10 percent and the governor
said that how we handle this weekend
will have an impact on how we recover
from this
economically